I just finished creativity Inc and at
Campbell the author and co-founder of
Pixar starts the book talking about a
table they love this table and they've
been using it for 13 years people sat
facing each other and any flow seated
along the walls which naturally led the
directors and producer or the people at
the top of the hierarchy to be seated at
the center of the table so the heart of
the conversations happened here and the
further you were the less likely you
were to say something one day they
happen to have a meeting in a smaller
room with a square table here all sides
were facing each other including any
overflow and that day they realized they
had better interaction automatic eye
contact and equal participation which is
kind of crucial for Creative
organizations our environments are full
of these invisible forces that have a
huge impact on how we behave